sit down we have to talk what is it
there's an important detail that we
forgot to attend to we need birthdays oh
no thank you this guy i saw at a
restaurant had a birthday they set his
food on fire and then blew on it
well nevertheless we have to have them
and we have to know how old we are for
some reason we're expected to act our
age and we don't even know what that is
how are we supposed to figure it out
well we're smart well guess how old
would you say i am
i'm going to say
35.
what's so funny that is actor john
lithgow on third rock from the sun
portraying an alien in human form
professor dick solomon loved that show
yeah this year marks the 25th
anniversary of the sitcom that earned
him three emmys the stage and screen
veteran is also known for playing
winston churchill on the crown and other
important figures in history roger ailes
comes to mind now lithgow is reprising
his iconic portrayal of serial killer
arthur mitchell on dexter for the
upcoming special series dexter new blood
it premieres next month on showtime
which of course is division of viacom
cbs and john lithgow joins us now john
good morning good morning it feels wrong
to say you're very convincing as a
serial killer but you are
but you are i'll take that as a
compliment
what was it like to step back into this
character after 10 years wonderful just
great to see them again you wouldn't
think so but
but uh doing a serial killer on dexter
was really really fun
how do you even prepare for something
like that since it's so foreign i know
it's called acting i know it's called
well what do you do the good news is the
writers prepare for you they and i was
hired last minute you know uh
actually i ran into an actor who had
been
offered the role before i had a month
ago i won't tell you who it was give us
initials no no
it was a it was a brilliant show and
michael c hall is a wonderful actor
yeah it's great to see him again uh
third rock from the sun is also a
brilliant show i just lit up when i saw
a little bit of that yeah i always made
it i know we were watching you watch you
yeah you could tell that it fills you up
i think i'm hilarious
[Laughter]
what is it like when you think back to
that show did you know at the time it
was going to be a show that 25 years
later we should be talking about you
never know uh you're always just
throwing it out there but we were having
so much fun
i i honestly think i'll live an extra 10
years fueled by all that laughter we
just laughed all the time would you
consider a reboot a rebut would you
consider a reboot
since you enjoyed it i don't know i'm a
little old for it it was it was john
what's old come on
now you were a presenter uh at the tony
awards and you're a tony award winner
yourself what was it like to celebrate
broadway again well it was
a fantastic evening everybody there felt
that way and i got to present the award
to danny burstein
very dear friend of mine who'd been
nominated seven times and he finally won
it was it was a great evening yeah
broadway in new york i mean it's
synonymous yeah
and you light up when you talk about the
art and the craft of being an actor um
what is your message to everybody that
are back on stage here in new york well
theater survives i mean it the
enthusiasm with which everybody's going
back to the theater now just shows you
how how starved we've been of
not just
not just theater but all of the arts so
much of the arts is a communal
experience and
you know pandemic has taken away
communal experiences
well you're also sitting here as a
best-selling author may i hold up your
book of course all right his latest book
is called a confederate a confederacy of
dumpty's i like that title uh portraits
of american scoundrels and verse and you
actually name names and take numbers in
this book what what go ahead no no what
what is your attraction to scoundrels
and we should also point out you did the
illustrations yes that was also a new
thing for you well this has been a sort
of white-hot political era these last
few years and i have very strong
convictions and responses to politics
but i'm much more an entertainer than a
pundit so i found my way
of satire was my way of being both
an entertainer and expressing myself you
do engage in one bit of historical
punditry which i think is important to
note here uh you refer to fictions that
become facts as they age is that a
general rule you find from history
you know history is very very tricky
that way thank god for historians and i
tip my you're married to one yeah
my wife
is very much an inspiration for creating
this book
look at
contemporary politics from the point of
view of what's happened over the last
200 years it's been going back and
finding these extraordinary characters
painted in bold strokes just like the
people we've been living with for the
last few years yeah you say john that
fun is the best antidote to ulcerous
rage yeah that's right well it's better
to respond
with satire than with for example
storming the capital that's right let's
go thank you you're the best we'll be
right here very good point